please to have of the host of man versus
food available only on Travel Channel
the sixth season of Travel Channel's man
vs. food premieres Monday December 4th
at 9:00 Eastern Time pleased to have
Casey Webb here in studio good to see
you circuit is the you sir is there
anything what's the first thing I never
really I rarely ask this event sure no
of course since you are the man right
who goes against food food you versus
food battlin is there anything you
refuse to eat no actually as long as
it's as long as it's for human
consumption I'm down okay well I mean
there are things that people consider of
edible for human like what I would
consider edible for human consumption
like what you just concocted on the fly
over that pizza
no it's pizza but there was you put some
hot stuff on it pepper flakes no heat
rich I'm just a lot of heat got the heat
guy I'm definitely gonna brine the
system no but is this is this part of
being the host of man vs. food that you
must be willing to eat anything if we
look back to the first season I've
definitely been scorched but I'm not
gonna you know you have any details I
want people to know but yeah there's
definitely I take on heat challenges for
sure you take on heat challenges oh
that's really hot whether it be you know
Ghost Pepper Kelly I know Reaper you
know it's cool scale over a million
which is hot hotter than a jalapeno so
which is more challenging on man versus
food for you Casey
is the quality or the quantity so
quality being spicy well just in terms
of what you like to eat right that's
what you don't or you have to eat
copious amounts in an absurd amount of
time that's allotted to you by the
Travel Channel
there's only so much time eat these
things so the spicy stuff gets you
I do like spicy and all of it tastes
great the first couple bites but then
when he starts sinking your teeth into
you know larger quantities at three
pounds a four pound a five pound
challenge this you kinda you kind of go
you're almost like in a
you know like a Vision Quest he goes
somewhere else you take yourself
somewhere else you know they say the
zone that's where I go is there any
preparation that you can do for
something like this yeah you know I mean
the thing is when you're when you're
full you gotta stop eat right that's it
yeah usually you know when you're done
you're done
no I I don't know preparation is a lot
of karate and Chinese herbs works
working pretty good
is that simultaneous yes consuming herbs
and practicing my Krag disparate that
would be yeah I can't divulge my trade
secret like oregano and painting the
fence at the very scene some yard work
and you know eat some herbs at the same
time
Casey Webb the host of man vs. food
we're again season six premieres Monday
at 9:00 Eastern Time I could not help
but notice the episode you went to the
great City of Milwaukee yes you ate an
absurd amount of corned beef right right
this Rami and beef all of that simples
bread and who was sitting directly to
your right while you were attempting to
eat this stuff our love and beloved ex
baseball commissioner Bud Selig what
stealing amazing we had seconds of his
time and he had seconds of his time busy
man he's not a busy man he was he was he
busy doing the only cars I think he was
eating his pickles and drinking his diet
coke no he uh you know why we told him
about the challenge he was excited for
me and uh uh yeah we got him on camera
which is great it was a very gracious
but yet he seemed busy you did he really
for me is there he didn't he didn't lock
the food out he didn't do anything like
and it's this place it's telling this is
it was right it was not gonna lock
anybody out right now he's more than
happy to watch me enjoy as you say there
was a time
oh that's a good Bud Selig sports
reference was it a tie yeah oh right now
if you remember that all-star game I use
at that all-star game and you actually
put on as they would say in baseball the
tools of ignorance you caught for the
for the Brewers on that day you actually
now and we played you know I played
catch with the guys
incredible to be in the stadium right
and get some advice from right
they were just crud they've been they
were crushing it when we were there yeah
there you are with some Milwaukee
Brewers the audience there you are I'm
sure today I'm glad that would've been
awkward particularly all left me all
right now you're from Casey Webb here
again Travel Channel's man versus food
December 4th 90s turn is the Monday
premiere date of off season six you're
from Jersey your Jersey girl yeah little
silver yeah that's where I change
where's little silver del 2fo that's our
Jersey expert over there I'm from
Livingston so little silver I remember I
think I'm gonna guess but where are you
it's that's how you call it a Solomon
ala pan you say it the way you want to
say don't listen these guys man our pan
we're gonna call Manalapan what's the
what exit is that mine red bag is 109
yeah I love asking the question is for
for up from from great adventure where I
always used to go there but did you ever
any specific sports teams that you root
for growing up in New Jersey yeah so my
parents are both New Yorkers my mom's
from Hell's Kitchen my dad's from the
Bronx so growing up my father is
obviously Yankees fan some pretty much
made me Yankees fans so you know before
the old stadium was torn down we go to a
bunch of those games Giants of course
yeah my dad I was born into that was
forced to be a Giants fan which I'm
happy to be you know I missed the days
of my father's scream of the TV Parcells
yeah you know yeah it's I find it ironic
that somebody who eats anything yeah in
man versus food has a parent from a
place called Hell's Kitchen right have
you ever noticed the irony of that
what's this what's the new so any again
you've been working in restaurants as
well since so what's the worst what is
the worst restaurant gig you've ever had
would that be washing dishes with that
you know that was a start so yeah it was
pretty grueling you know let's say I'm
washing other people's dishes I had a
hard time washing my own dishes the kids
yeah okay okay
always been a messy kid so you know
what's the worst tip you've ever had
nothing really yeah
did was that I wouldn't I would never
tip nothing me neither but never don't
ever do that was that was that don't
ever do that by the way that's on if you
want to if you want to get there that
yes it was it was it what was the story
New York City just poor service I think
it was had something to do with the
night before and I know it's probably
wearing my night on me and I think they
realized that I was not giving them the
best service and so you know okay so
what give give me just one thing out of
season six that's coming up that you're
going to eat or attempt to eat worst or
I should be looking out for in terms of
any of the competitions of versus food
so we let out two episodes that are
coming up on December 4th it's LA in
Boston okay Boston it was such a monster
city super fans and I you know one of
the things the dishes that we we
showcase there is the pilgrim which is a
giant Thanksgiving sandwich which is
Thanksgiving between two buns so really
yeah awesome burger company turkey
mashed potatoes turkey damn so do you
fall asleep during the middle I thought
I knocked out he smelled it and that's
in Boston wasn't Boston in Los Angeles
they don't serve stuff like that no
gluten free food versus man no yes I'm
striving to get there one day
gluten free yeah LA was was it was a
zombie burrito giant spicy burrito if
the kitchen stink basically and that was
you know at least doing some fun things
with food the fusion was a Mexican
Korean Japanese fusion place Genki yaki
yeah as a party Genki Jacques you gotta
tune in and see what happens by the way
that sounds like a a great leftfielder
that's coming over right we're taking up
with a posting fee yeah million dollars
just a negotiator he's really spicy that
guy watch out for him man versus food
Casey Webb the host of man vs. food on
Travel Channel against season 6 on
Travel Channel
check it out at night Eastern Time it's
fun meeting you man
wait let us know when you're in Los
Angeles next well we'll do something
together
amazing love - you got it Casey web for
more Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app